- Thank you very much.
I am Rohini Pande.
I'm one of the members
of the development community here at Yale.
And so, on behalf of all of
us, thank you for coming.
We've had a great day of discussions.
So, I want to just first start
because I know these
things get lost otherwise
is by thanking a number of people
who've really helped make this what it is.
So, our deputy director
at EGC Aishwarya Ratan.
She and Jillian Stallman have really led
from the front on this.
So, thank you to both of them.
On our comm's team,
Vestal McIntyre and then helping
with a lot of the finance
stuff was Dave Cowell.
We had a bunch of volunteers
who as you've seen
in the rooms throughout the
day, so to thank them as well.
And finally Shannon, who's
really been helping us
a lot on the Yale Center.
So, thank you very much.
I think none of this
would've been possible
without all of that.
(people clapping)
Before we get started,
I also wanted to share
that next year NUDC
will be held at Harvard.
So, we have a location for it
and hopefully the weather
will be almost as good,
but we'd like you to remember Yale
as the place of the best weather.
(people laughing)
So, let me start really,
I'm going to talk for a
very little amount of time,
but I just wanted to
spend a couple of minutes
on why we chose to do the Plenary panel
on the lessons learned
on poverty measurement
through household panel surveys.
So, I think increasingly
what you hear a lot of talk
about is you know, the
excitement around big data
and the many ways in which big data,
and combinations of field
experiments can be used
to learn many features of development.
But in the end, I think there's
also a lot of recognition
that development is a
very long run process
and if we both want to learn
about how these processes evolve
and how people cope, for
instance with shocks and crises,
it's going to be critical
to have long run data
collection enterprises.
And this is something actually
when Chris, when he was here,
he and Mark Rosenzweig very
deliberately put in place
a system to collect long
run data in Ghana and India.
And we are delighted
that today is an occasion
where in addition to hearing about much
of this data collection, we
are also able to announce
the public release of
the first three waves
of the Ghana panel.
And so, for those of you are
more technologically savvy
than me, apparently if you
scan that QR code there,
you'll be able to be led
directly to the data site
that now has the first three
waves, the Ghana panel.
So, let me start by just
briefly introducing our speakers
and then I'll hand it over to Chris Udry.
So, we are going start
with some opening comments
from Chris Udry who is the
Robert E and Emily King,
Professor of Economics at Northwestern.
I really think Chris
needs no introduction,
but he's really been a pioneer,
I think an inspiration for many of us
and in demonstrating how
you can both, you know,
collect long term panel data
but also, I think, bring together
many different approaches
to help us learn about
development trajectories.
After he introduces it,
he's going to hand it over
to his two colleagues at Northwestern,
Andre Nickow and Sam Ampaw.
Andre Nickow is a research manager
at the Global Poverty Research Lab
and he received his PhD
from Northwestern in 2017.
His interest span a wide range
within development studies
with a special focus in
evaluation methodology
and political economy.
He will combine his
presentation with Sam Ampaw
who is a postdoctoral
fellow at the "GPRL".
And his research focuses
on poverty, healthcare,
health education, digital technologies
and non pharma entrepreneurship.
He received his PhD from Nottingham
and before that his degree
is from University of Ghana.
After we hear about the Ghana panel,
we're going to turn to Graciela
Teruel who'll talk to us
about the "Mexican Family Life Survey",
which as many of you may know
is an extremely impressive panel survey
that has been used in many papers.
Graciela is the director
of the Research Institute
of Social Development
an equity of University
Iberoamericano in Mexico City.
She holds a PhD in economics from UCLA.
And then finally, we'll turn
to our own Mushfiq Mobarak,
who is the professor of
economics at Yale and at SOM.
So, I'm not worried about him getting lost
in getting his way here.
So, he will hopefully come soon
and he's going to talk to us
about the "Cox's Bazaar Panel",
which is a panel of refugee migrants.
And so, I think quite a different setting.
But with that, let me
hand it over to Chris.
- Thank you, thanks Rohini.
(people clapping)
(audio goes out)
This is an exciting day
to have the Ghana panel publicly released.
So, there was a time that
high quality data from low
and middle income countries
was really scarce.
W. Arthur Lewis and Ester
Boserup could change the way
we looked at the world by
having a few tables of data
from customs records and a
few anthropology case studies.
This weekend makes it abundantly clear
that that's just not true anymore.
The rich data
(microphone back feed high pitched noise)
the rich data that's available from RCTs,
expenditure surveys,
from administrative data,
from remote sensing data.
Their availability is
facilitating really rapid progress
in how we understand the world.
In this
setting
of rich data,
as Rohini actually started
to mention, what's the use
of these
big
household panel survey datas?
Data sets.
When Mark and I started
thinking about this,
our goal was to
set up a lab
in which people could think
about development in new ways.
We thought that by committing
to a very long term comprehensive
and coordinated set of studies
that obtain individual's,
that obtain data on individual's life
course as they move through
the process of development and the built,
and natural environment in
which they're operating,
we could provide tools that would lead
to unexpected insights,
that we'd find things
that we didn't know were happening.
And so, that's what I'm hoping
these data can be used for.
And we have
I actually have two slides I wanna show.
Yeah.
Blank one.
(audience laughing)
- [Rohini] No, you got to go back.
- No, that's what I want.
- Okay, great.
- Okay.
So, this is what panel data
gets you fundamentally.
It gets you what's happening
to an individual over time.
And so that's just a scatter plot
of
food expenditure
per adult equivalent in households,
in wave one and wave three
of the Ghana panel data.
So, those are separated
by, for a 12 years.
And so there's guys in the upper left
who started off quite poor
and are now doing very well.
There's guys in the lower right
who were doing pretty well
in wave one and are doing badly now.
What distinguishes them?
What's driving this?
And so, that's the sort
of fundamental thing
that we know about from panel data.
We can track people over time
and see what's happening.
What
is unique about
the data sets
that we'll be talking about today
is the breadth of information that we have
about these same individuals.
So,
Sam and Andre are gonna talk to you
about some of the specifics.
Let me just give you an example.
We asked people,
"what do you think about when
you fall asleep at night?"
And they told us, and so,
here's
the words
that come up most
for people in households that
have done better over time,
that have gone from that lower right,
that are in the upper left of
that scatter plot they had.
And here's the words that were
mentioned more
by the ones who were falling.
And I don't know if this means anything,
this is not actually something
that I'm gonna study.
But the point is that by
drawing together information
from
various
widely dispersed parts of people's lives,
we might make unexpected connections.
This is gonna come up later, I think,
when we have a discussion.
But let me now turn it over to
Sam.
- All right, thank you Chris.
So, I have a text to introduce
briefly the "Ghana Panel"
and I'll do that with Andre.
We have five minutes each so I would skip
or not go into so much details.
We can talk about that later.
So, this is the outline we are using.
So, we would look at the
sampling design and attrition,
the instruments and then topics covered
under the "Ghana Panel", and
then the field procedures.
And then Andre would come in
with some descriptive statistics
and some exploratory transition analysis.
Okay,
so
so the "Ghana Panel" follows
a two-stage sampling procedure.
The first stage was the
selection of clusters,
334 clusters.
And in each of these clusters,
we had 15 households selected.
So, that gave a total of 5,010
households.
Okay, so there's a unique feature
I would want to highlight here,
which is we track moved households
and split-off household members.
That is breakaway household members.
I'm sure you might be,
there's something puzzling going on there.
Why would we have 5,009
4,774
and then
5,669
you might be guessing.
So the next slide would
show us what is happening.
So you find that indeed in
the wave one we had 5,009,
surveyed households. But
moving to the wave two,
we find that of that sample
attrited for various reasons it
could be the death of all the
household members refusal,
it could be migration outside
Ghana or we were just not able
to reach these households.
Okay, so
that was it.
And so you also find that for
the split of household members
we had 965
but we don't trace all of them.
We don't follow all of them.
So we randomly select some to follow.
Okay, so that is how come
we still ended up with the 4,774 but we
were, the same thing happened.
But we're fortunate for the
third way to have located 396
households who were not
located in the second wave.
So that is how come we have
a greater than number for the
third wave. So I'll move on.
Yeah, so the instrument,
we started using computer
assisted personal interviewing
since the wave two.
The first wave was a paper based
and for the wave two we used Blaze.
And beyond that we use service
CTO for both the wave three
and then four.
Okay,
so here are some topics
you can find in the
"Ghana Panel", and
we for the fourth wave,
we have introduced some new
questions which I mean we find
relevant in recent times.
So Ghana recently introduced
some policies and we think it
best to include such questions.
So an example is the,
is this an electronic transaction levy?
So we wanted to know what people
thought of it and then some
feedback cause this
was very controversial.
And then there's also the
planting for food and jobs.
So we ask questions also on
that and we also include social
media questions.
Okay, so if anyone is also interested
in our internet speed data,
we have it in there. So um,
quickly the field procedure,
I'll just run through it cause
I have just two minutes left.
So like I said, we have the
household tracking, we did,
this is mainly for the
wave four, we did this.
First we used phones to track
the households to know if they
are still where they are before
we went on to look for them.
So that is what proceed,
I mean start we started with
and then we had the teams and
then we put them together and
then we do these before these
protocols. We do a district entry,
community entry and then
an in person tracking
once the
teams are in the communities.
So I would just skip to also,
once they submit the data,
we go through some quality checks.
We can think of high
frequency checks. We do that,
it seems like a real
time data quality check.
So once they submit that data to us,
we go through and then check
for potential outliers.
For instance, there are
times for several reasons,
tiredness you can, you
could find age being 3000,
that doesn't really sound
right.
So we prompt them and
then we go through this.
And then we also have the back
checks where we call back the
survey households to ask same
some questions. For instance,
we could ask the household,
we could ask for the number
of plots and just to see if it
corresponds with what the,
we have in the data
submitted by the field team.
And also we have the
high frequent, I'm sorry,
we had a fields monitoring
here. So this study is,
we started integrating our CTs into the
"Ghana Panel"
starting with a third wave.
And this is one study which
I think creates and then some
other cohorts did.
So I am particularly
interested in this or I find it
exciting because what it
does is that it shows how
livelihood support joint
pandemics could lead people to
adhere to public health directives.
And so in this case it use
the COVID 19 and then social
distancing. Okay, so the question is,
if we
give these monies to people,
are they likely to social distance?
And it finds positive
effects. So I'll turn it over to Andre now
for him to go through.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- I think you you go,
forward.
- Oh, forward like
(indistinct)
So thanks very much.
It's been a great conference
so far and I'm just gonna use
the next few minutes to talk
about a few of the types of
exploratory data analysis that
can be very quickly, readily,
easily done with "Ghana Panel" data.
So we decided to take three
example variables that represent
different types of, you know, different.
(high pitched feedback)
First we have the food
consumption per capital,
which is the sum across all food types.
Of purchased,
received as gift and produced food.
Then we have the probability
of poverty index as a proxy for
poverty,
which gives the percentage
probability that a household
falls below a particular
say, prosperity threshold.
In this case we're using
the national poverty line.
And then third, the "Kessler
Distress Scale", sorry,
the probability of poverty
index comes from 10 questions of
assets, household size,
that kind of thing.
The Kessler has 10 questions
about how often in the past
month people have felt, you
know, depressed, anxious,
et cetera.
And the idea is that it's a
non-clinical construct that's
associated with clinical
constructs like anxiety and
depression.
So is,
you can see for food
consumption went way up between,
oh and food consumptions
also adjusted for CPI,
I should mention, went way
up between waves one and two,
but then back down waves two and three.
Similarly the Kessler went
down between waves one and two,
which is good, that means less distress.
Then back up just a little
wave three PPI went down
consistently,
but only a little bit
between waves two and three.
So that we could have
seen from across sections.
But to take up some of the
themes that Chris was showing in
his graph,
we can also look at poverty
transitions or just more
generally development trajectories
and stories of particular
households and understanding
what's associated with upward
mobility and downward mobility.
So here for each of the three variables,
we reduce the sample to only
households that we can link
between waves one and three.
And then we take above and
below median on the outcome in
question for waves one,
same for wave three.
And because it's gonna
be symmetrical here,
we're only showing the
below median in wave one.
So this also gives a chance
to compare mobility of these
three outcomes as food consumption.
You can see there's a
good amount of mobility.
PPI not so much,
79% of the households who
were below median in wave one
stayed below median in wave three.
And then Kessler also more mobility.
So of course we can't say for
sure what's measurement error
and what's actually capturing things.
PPI should be more precise,
but also because of the,
the types of questions asked.
but also since it involves durable assets,
there's likely something real going on.
So now to break this
out, just one more step.
One of the biggest social
distinctions we could say in Ghana
is North versus South
social and geographical and
agroecological.
So there's a lot going on here.
And so we want to see is mobility
higher for Northern or for
Southern, et cetera.
So.
So now starting with food consumption,
we can see that in the South
below median there's a good
amount of mobility.
A lot of people in, who are
below median in South in wave
one were above median by wave three.
But the situation was not
so great for below median
households in the North.
They were overwhelmingly still
below median by wave three,
12 years later.
And then a similar story
for above and below.
Now we're not controlling for
regional price differences,
so that could be part of this.
But as we'll see the pattern's
the same for PPI for below
median, not so much for above median.
So this is a much starker
table as you can see,
especially point you towards
the second row where 96% of the
households who are below
median in the PPI index in wave
one, stay below median wave
three.
And so then psychological
distress, on the other hand,
there's a lot more movement.
And so of course we're thinking
not only about the actual
trends,
but about how these different
variables are capturing
different constructs that
might vary more quickly in real
life. And we're thinking
about potential threats to,
you know, measurement error
and other validity concerns.
So these are some density
plots like Chris showed.
And you can see on left we have the South,
most of the households are above the line,
meaning that they had experienced
upward mobility and it's
the opposite for the South. So
I'll actually wrap up there.
There are some other interesting
findings with farms and
plots, but yeah,
so we very much hope that you'll
use the data and share the
results with us and maybe
present them next year at
any UDC. So thank you very much.
(audience applause)
- [Rohini Pande] Graciela
we'll now turn to you
to talk about their experiences in
Mexico.
- Sure.
- Can you put the,
- Yeah, the slide is actually coming up.
- Well, thank you very much
for the invitation to be here.
I'm gonna be talking about
poverty measurement in Mexico and
specifically using the
"Mexican Family Live Survey".
So um,
one second.
How do I do it?
- That that was the
- The green one.
- Oh, there, its okay.
All right.
So poverty measurement in
Mexico official is done by
CONEVAL,
the Mexican council for the
evaluation of social policy.
And they have a mandate,
it has to be done every two years at the,
at the national level
and at the state level.
And they have to use official
data coming from the National
Bureau of Statistics.
And the indicators have to be
decomposable and it has the,
the National Bureau of
Statistics produces that income
expenditure survey, which is
a series of cross sections.
So what we use is actually
that information to produce the
official measurements.
So this is basically the
methodology that we use.
So we have on the X
axis social deprivation,
which goes from the right
to the left if you have
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 social deprivation.
And on the y axis you have
basically income economic
wellbeing.
So the interaction between
these two dimensions is what
gives you poverty.
So extreme poverty is
the red box and it's,
it basically is three
deprivations or more and below a
minimum income level.
And it's basically 10% of the
population across all years in
the last 10 years is basically the same.
And then we have moderate poverty,
which is if you have at least
one deprivation and you're
below this upper income level,
so you're moderately poor
and it's basically 36% of the
population in that quadrant.
And then the rest of the country
is divided into non-poor,
which is the green quadrant,
which is basically 19%.
And then you have the
vulnerable by income,
which is like 5% of the population,
which is those below
the income poverty line,
but no social deprivation
or the vulnerable by social
deprivations, which are
those that have high,
high income but have
some sort of deprivation.
So basically if you look at
poverty measurements in Mexico,
the, the indicators,
they don't typically change across time.
And so the question is,
we don't know anything
about poverty transition.
So we see 10%, 10%, 10% of
people being in extreme poverty.
And the question is whether
there's actually no mobility out
of poverty,
are people living in extreme
poverty able to ever get out of
poverty or not?
So we're gonna use the "MXFLS",
which is this longitudinal study,
to try to answer and look
at some of this questions.
So if a person is born poor,
will she
or he
die
being poor?
Is there social mobility as
measured by these changes in
poverty status?
And is there a way out of poverty?
So I'm going to present some of the,
exercise that we did to try
to answer this question.
So we're gonna use the
Mexican Family Life Survey,
which is the only
nationally representative
panel
multi topic purpose survey in Mexico.
And it allows to study
associations between different
indicators of welfare because
it has everything you can
think of, I'm sure it has.
So you can go into the web, I'm not,
I I don't have a lot of time to,
to go into a lot of details,
but it collects biomarkers,
objective and subjective
indicators of health,
interviews, everyone
in the household as opposed
to the representative
respondent.
And it also collects information
about the community prices
and infrastructure at
the local level. It's a,
a longitudinal survey, as I said,
it relocates and re-interviews baseline,
the baseline sample collected in 2002
and it
tracks
individuals both within Mexico
and into the United States.
So there's three waves.
We actually field it started
fielding a fourth wave in,
2018,
but we,
it's really painful to say this but,
the government actually cut
funding and we couldn't even
finish the, the fourth wave.
So it's basically like half done.
Approximately,
we started collecting 35,000
individuals in the baseline and
we're about 40,000 respondents
by the last wave.
So I'm not gonna talk about
this because I don't have a lot
of
time.
The only thing that I'm
gonna say is that, why are
longitudinal data useful for
the study of measurement?
So as Chris was saying,
is obviously to track individuals
across time and to see,
look at transitions in and out of poverty,
that's one advantage.
And another one is that since
it's the same households
across time,
you can use information from
different waves to complement
and to, to, to complement the study
of property measurement. So for example,
we use expenditure as opposed to income
because we followed
these people along the
years that we, we thought,
and we proved that it was
better to use expenditure when
using poverty measurements.
But also, for example,
we didn't have information about
food deprivation in all the
waves, only in the third wave.
So we used that information to
model food deprivation in the
first two waves. So that's
one of the advantages.
So I'm not gonna stop on this.
So what are the social
deprivations? Access to education,
health, social security, housing, basic,
basic services and food.
So we're gonna use this
definition of poverty
in Mexico
and well, I'm just gonna show you, ,
I cannot really stop here.
But if you use MXFLS as a
cross section and compare to
what indicators are obtained
using the CONEVAL efficient
measures, the numbers are
basically very similar.
So we're going to use for this
exercise that I'm gonna show
you, we're gonna classify
poverty into four groups.
The first is chronic poverty.
So those are that in the three
waves we're always classified
as poor.
Then we have the persistent poverty.
So comprised of people who
experience poverty in two of the
three
waves
and transitory poverty,
those who were
classified
as four in one
and then none poor,
never classified as poor.
So,
so we basically have all these
kinds of combinations across
the three waves.
And so what are the results
that we get? So this is
how is, how is it distributed
among these four groups?
So it's basically 25% almost
equally distributed between the
four groups.
And another way of reading it
is that
75%
of the population
in Mexico, in this 10
years of the study period,
have been poor at least once.
So this is a,
different way of
interpreting these results.
And if you look at, for
example, the extreme poverty,
which is the, the lowest one,
extreme chronic poverty
is less than 2% in Mexico,
extreme persistent poverty,
5% transitory, 16%.
So another way of putting it
is that one out of every five
people in Mexico have been in
extreme poverty in this last,
in this study period of 10 years.
So,
people, if you look at, for example,
at the official poverty
measurements in, in Mexico,
those are,
those official indicators are
used to delineate or design
public policies.
So public policies based on
those first scraps that I show
you, or those first statistics
guide you to very different
policies as if you used
these longitudinal or
panel
results.
So the
conclusions would be different.
So public policy is currently
designed by using the static
groups.
So policies aimed at helping
these groups may be focused
only on short term poverty alleviation,
and not looking at the
structural causes of poverty.
So that's something that can be done.
I'm not going to stop at this.
I will share my slides later
with you guys so you can see
what the data looks like in
term of the chronicity of
poverty.
But determinants of current
poverty differ significantly
from determinants of transitory poverty.
Sorry.
And they're very,
they're very different depending
obviously on the income
poverty line that you use.
Poverty in general is associated
with a number of adults in
the households because those
are the ones working and those
are the ones that are generating income.
But specifically chronicity
of poverty is very much
associated with schooling
and health conditions.
So more schooling and
better health leads to lower
chronicity of poverty as one would expect.
So employment and particularly
former employment are the
cornerstone for permanent
poverty reduction.
Let me just go to the last slide,
which talks about the lessons learned.
And I would say that
longitudinal approaches
give more information
and information that is more
suited in order to delineate or
design protected public policies.
This multipurpose component
also adds a lot because you can
use a lot of, of breadth of,
of social demographic indicators to,
to design these antipoverty projects.
And
typically,
and this is something that I
will just be my my last comment
that I think is something very
nice for you guys working on
these topic is that a
lot of our countries,
especially in Latin
America, are suffering,
are suffering from our
democracies, are suffering,
and our we're shaking.
And also the data collection
is shaking in our countries.
And there's some countries
in Latin America that are not
being able to collect data,
to study poverty or to
study anything else.
So it's,
it's a very good idea for efforts,
that efforts can be done
from the academia, academic
point of view to collect this
kind of data so that we can
produce poverty estimates and we
can compare poverty estimates
over time. So I'll stop here.
- [Rohini Pande] Thank you Graciela.
(audience clapping)
Fantastic, and I think a great segue
to an academic who's gonna talk
us, talk to us about collect
data collection efforts.
So Musfiq, over to you.
- Thank you. I'm sorry I
walked into the stage late,
I couldn't find the building.
(people laughing)
So I mean,
given the excellent presentations
we've heard from Ghana and
Mexico, I'll do something different.
First of all, I won't have slides,
but I'll try to focus on how
the specific activity that we
have in southern Bangladesh
in Cox which our district,
is different, but also how
it connects to other efforts.
And, but first, before
getting, getting into it, I,
when Rohini, Aishwarya,
the leadership team here
asked me to do this,
I thought it was a fantastic
idea to have a Plenary session
that highlights like
data, public goods, right?
'Cause often in these conferences
we have like some special
talk that's elevated, whereas I,
I feel like this is exactly
the type of conversation we
should be having and hopefully
this incentivizes people to
also contribute to various
data, public goods.
But, but I should say more broadly,
Rohini, Aishwarya, Nick, Bestel,
Jillian, everybody, fantastic.
Professionally organized
and managed conference.
Thank you so much, from all of us.
Okay, so this the "Cox Bazaar
Panel Survey", "CBPS" it's,
focused on a very unusual
and very specific population.
The Rohingya refugees,
we had a large influx of Rohingya
refugees from Myanmar into
Bangladesh in 2017.
There were lots of Rohingyas before that.
And actually we started a,
a data collection process
with them even prior to 2017.
And then suddenly in the
middle of preparing, you know,
we had close to a million people
who showed up in the matter
of a couple of months in a
country that wasn't very,
well prepared to handle
such a large influx.
And, and so, and at that point
to Yale leadership's credit,
everybody was thinking about,
okay, how do we contribute?
And that's, we,
we decided that maybe we should
start asking some questions
and collecting some information
that might be useful for
policy, right?
And so that led to identifying, you know,
we need to understand what's
happening with this particular
population, right?
That's important because I
mean, there was gonna be a,
a case in the International
Court of Justice, right?
And it was important that
their voices be heard because
Aung San Suu Kyi was presenting
the Myanmar voice, right?
And so we needed systematic
data and then the Myanmar's
commentary always was, Oh, these
like journalistic accounts,
they're not representative, et cetera.
So we wanted to get some
representative information about
the trauma that the Rohingya
had had, had experienced.
But it was also clear to me
as soon as I started visiting
the area that what happened
in five years or 10 years to
this population, initially in 2017,
everybody was just focused
on how do we provide the most
basic services, just food and
shelter, sanitation, water,
et cetera, right?
Everybody was just focused on
that as they should have been.
That's, that's what
was needed immediately.
But, but it was also clear
to me that five or 10 years,
what happens to this population
over time will depend on how
local politics changes, right?
So the Bangladesh government,
made our, prime minister
made a very
brave decision at that point that yeah,
of course we are going to welcome them.
We were refugees once, which
is true only 50 years ago.
And, and so it's our
responsibility to make room,
but as soon as people start
getting impatient with their
presence, because the
people who live in the area,
they themselves are
deprived and poor, right?
So if they start getting impatient
and the politics changes,
that creates a much more
dangerous situation, right?
So therefore we decided to
do the survey not only of the
Rohingya, but what we
call the host community,
so people who were already living there,
and then there's a third
population of pre 2017 Rohingya
arrivals who were trying to, they were,
it was illegal for them to be there,
but they were trying to then
blend into the population,
but also to have a contrast,
not only the host community
that was immediately surrounding
the camps,
but host communities that were
farther away from the camps
just to have that contrast as well. Yeah.
And um,
so now let me,
now get into the details
of the data itself. So,
we decided to,
in order to create a sampling
frame and then have a sample
of 5,000 people that we would
follow around in a panel,
right?
We first had to have touchpoints
like kind of a sampling or,
or like a census type exercise.
So we had to have touchpoints
with about 55,000 people or
households. So what we
ended up doing was, okay,
so from those 55,000, we'll
choose these 5,000 to,
to survey intensively over time.
And the other 50,000 was we,
we just made it available
to researchers saying, look,
if you, here's a sampling frame,
we've already done that exercise,
that's something that
might be costly, right?
And we would welcome
anybody who has ideas on,
let's say they want to run
interventions that might be
beneficial to this population,
whether it's cash transfers or
psychosocial work, et cetera.
So researchers can come in
and use that sampling frame.
And if you want to do
intervention based experimental
research, you're allowed
to do that, right?
And,
and it's just the 5,000 households
that we wouldn't want to
start running interventions in
that sample because then they
would cease to be representative, right?
And that would undermine. So, so we,
we created these two subpopulations
50,000 of people who we
could run interventions
on versus not, right?
And the data are all publicly available,
I hope people choose
to use it. We are now,
we did one round of intensive
sort of in-person surveying,
and then we did multiple during Covid,
we did multiple rounds of
phone surveys to continue also
maintaining touchpoint so that
we could more easily track
them. As you can imagine,
this is a population that's
gonna be very difficult for us
to track over time,
precisely because they're
mobile and they don't want to be
there. They, they'd like to
get out as soon as they can.
And in fact,
the government relocated a
lot of them in a politically
contentious decision to shore
area, like a island type area.
And um,
Okay.
And then the other benefit of, you know,
having these two sub-populations
is that if you end up
running interventions in
like the, some, you know,
in some sub sample of the 50,000 people,
then with nice thing is that
you have 5,000, our sample
households, the panel
households who you could,
who you could use as a very,
very large control group,
right? So then if you run
experiments on, you know,
you choose 200 people or 500
people to run an experiment on
somewhere else, you have,
have you automatically,
as long as we maintain
measurement consistently in
measurement, then you could
use, you could use that.
So again, everyone's welcome to come and,
and do research here.
So yeah. One other thing,
one other point I'll mention
about the importance of the,
of a panel.
So there was an unintended
benefit during the Covid period,
which is that I learned that
like during Covid suddenly,
of course we had to all,
everybody had to stop our
in-person data collection
activities. But thankfully we had,
along with this sample and
other areas in Bangladesh,
we had a sample of people
whose statistical properties we
had some understanding of.
So we knew what adjustments
we'd have to make,
plus we had their phone numbers
and we also knew that the
phones were picked up only
three, four months before, right?
And so that allowed us to
quickly in March, 2020 itself
start doing high frequent high
frequency data collection for
these populations. And, and
so that, so for example,
actually across the Ghana survey
and other countries and the
Bangladesh surveys, we
ended up writing a paper.
So even though Chris and I
were colleagues for a decade,
we never managed to
write a paper together.
He left and during the
Covid period we did, right?
Thanks, thanks to all this data
and okay, so one, you know,
so one like sort of tangible
example of how the panel
dimension helps.
Now it turns out there's a
lot of seasonality, right?
Which is not a surprise to
any, any development economist,
like within,
within year there's a lot of
variation in people's outcomes.
And so Covid just happened
to hit in some countries
it happened to hit during a good period,
like a harvest period where
people had grain stocks in other
countries there were the
pre-harvest period, right?
And so we were learning,
thankfully, once you have the,
a lot of the pre Covid data, right?
You could track, you know,
as long as it was high frequency enough,
you could track what kind of
seasonal variation there was.
And that allowed us to say
that, look in this country,
maybe people aren't suffering
so much right now. Right?
But that's not good news because
relative to the same season
in a previous year, it was
actually really bad news, right?
This is why also I think when
we all contribute to these
kind of data, public goods,
they sometimes pay off dividends for,
for us in unanticipated ways.
And the final thing I'll
mention is about partnerships.
So even though Yale was willing
to, for the first round,
was willing to pay for
the survey themselves,
we ended up partnering with
the World Bank and UNHCR.
And that's been very useful
because those two organizations,
and other than funds and money,
they also have really good
convening power, right?
Which is really valuable. So for example,
the way our UNHCR
partnership works right now,
we figured out that they're not
particularly useful in terms
of like statistical decision
sampling frames, et cetera.
But the, the UNHCR country
representative is very,
very useful in telling us sort
of keeping the pulse of like,
what is it that we need to
know in the next round, right?
So essentially the partnership
we have is that they tell us,
okay,
here are the policy questions
that need to be answered so
that our research team can be
responsive exactly to that.
And here I should, I'm
here on stage talking,
but the person who's overtime
taken on the lead PI role,
Paola Lopez-Pena,
she's a Queens University and
she has been maintaining a lot
of those relationships. Thank you.
I'll stop there.
- Thanks very much.
(audience clapping)
- So we're a bit short of time,
but we wanted to take a
couple of questions from the
audience,
but let me start by abusing
my privilege as moderator
to ask a
question to the panelists and
any subset of them can answer,
which is,
we've heard a lot about these
fantastic data sets and as
Mushfiq highlighted,
it's really an amazing public
good that's been provided to
us.
But when I put on my hat of
thinking about when I'm talking
to our students or the young researchers,
we always emphasize that, you know,
don't start with the data
sets. Start with a question.
So I was curious how you would
like us to think about that,
given that we've been sitting
here and sort of saying,
here are all these data
sets that you should use.
So maybe Chris, I get you to start.
- [Chris Udry] Most of
you shouldn't use them.
(people laughing)
I think you,
get to be driven by your own interests,
but if those interests.
- [Mushfiq} Coincide.
- Coincide with, with the,
the extremely broad set of
data that's being collected in
each of these three surveys,
it's worth taking a look and
just playing around with it.
Yeah. And so the,
yeah,
even though your interest
might seem very different from
what people who have used the
data before have done that
doesn't mean it can't be used
for what you're interested in.
So just take a look. Yeah.
- Garciela? You have any other?
- [Garciela] Yeah, I would say in the,
the case of the "Mexican
Family Life Survey", it's a,
a very rich database has more than
2000 questions.
So basically, I mean, you can,
there's lots of things and
lots of modules that have not
been exploited.
So you can exploit obviously
the longitudinal component and
looking at very, very,
very different questions.
I say you go and,
and dig into the webpage
and I'm sure you'll find a,
a question you're interested in.
- [Mushfiq] So, so while, you know,
Rohani framed this as like
some tension between, you know,
data first or, or research
question first, right?
And I totally get that, you know,
my conversations with PhD students, we,
we also emphasize the same thing, but I,
don't think it always has
to be a dichotomy like that,
or it doesn't have to be
intention partly because I am just
continually amazed by young researchers,
PhD students unbounded
capacity for innovation, right?
So you have data and as long
as we do the simple boring
things of like, okay,
let's just make sure we ask
all the questions that seem
relevant,
rather than like thinking
about what are the interesting
questions.
Like people come up and then
they merge that data with like
other policy changes or
something and we're amazed at the
outcome. So for example, after the,
the collecting the cost with
our panel survey, right?
So I was always trying
to think about, okay,
how do I merge the Bangladesh side,
with Myanmar side given
that it's impossible,
especially in that particular
state in Myanmar where the
used to live, right?
To collect data. But we
were able to, you know,
one of our PhD students
who was here now, Jai Wen
who's at Harvard Business
School, so she knew about,
she works on conflict, she
knew about the conflict data.
And so we now merged those
two and have started thinking
about how the propensity for
the Myanmar military to engage
in genocidal acts, right?
Buried across different and what the,
what the trauma effects
were. Anyway, so I'm,
I'm not concerned that you'll
find fabulous things to do.
I don't even know what they are,
but
- That's the point.
Yeah.
- [Rohini] We take some questions
right there at the back?
I think some there's
someone with a mic who..
- [Audience Member] Hello.
Thank you for the talk about
panel.
- Introduce yourself.
- Oh, sorry, my name's Remy Levin.
I'm at the University of Connecticut.
I'm extremely happy that
you're talking about this
'cause I've
used both the "IFLS" and the "MXFLS"
in my research and I think
they're incredible data sets.
One thing that I want to ask
you though is as far as these
longitudinal data sets,
one of the kind of primary
constraints is how persistent
they're over time, right?
And so we've now gone a
decade without another wave of
the "MXFLS"
and we're coming up on seven
or eight years without another
wave of the "IFLS", and so I'm
just wondering if we're ever
going to see like, new
waves of these data sets.
'cause you know,
at some point they start
getting stale and there's more
things I'd like to do with the
data and it would be great if
we had more of it. You know,
that's, that's my question.
(people laughing)
- Well I feel exactly the same.
We did collect like 50% of the data
in 2018/19
We're actually trying to work on
weights
in order to,
to be able to use at least that part.
What we're doing as well is
contacting these people via
phone
for the ones that we have phones
so that we can sort of keep
contact with them. So in,
in the possibility that we,
we could collect another wave,
then it would be easier because
I mean, tracking people is,
is hard in Mexico,
especially now given obviously
all the insecurity there is.
So,
so keeping contact with them
so that they don't forget about
us, it's crucial.
So we're trying to do that and
we're doing everything we can
to come up with the funds to
continue the study because we
believe it's,
it's a unique study and
especially from the family life
survey,
the "Mexican Family Life Survey"
has this extra component of
tracking individuals to the US
So it's, it's really unique.
Yeah.
- [Mushfiq] Can I add something.
- Yeah. Okay, very good.
There's a question down there.
They can come down so you
can add...
- Oh yeah.
So I'll just add that your
point about the phone surveys,
it's,
that's something that's become
a really big change in the
way that all of us do research, right?
Like the work from home type
regime change that's happened,
that's also happened with the
way we are surveying things.
And it's a great way to cheaply
collect high frequency data
and also maintain contact
with the panel of households
so that
the in-person survey where
the finding rates increase.
- [Audience Member] I'd love to hear
what you all think about doing more
individual level stuff in those surveys.
The ability to measure
individual level poverty,
for example, within households,
it's very important for
all kinds of gender issues.
Of course, I know there are
trade offs for agriculture,
also very important looking
at individual level plots,
things like that. Just,
just wondering what you
all think about that.
- Guess you are the
individual plot person.
(people laughing)
- So
I think it depends on the
context and the question and so
we're trying,
we're striving to collect data
at the individual level where
we can, and it's relevant.
So obviously
anthropometrics is at
the individual level,
businesses and farming and
income is at the individual
level.
Consumption we don't even try
just because it's too much of
a challenge. Although we'd be open to,
to adding a module to try to
do that in, in some sub sample,
for example.
Yeah.
- The lady behind?
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
So I wanted to ask a question
to Mushfiq about this very,
very challenging survey among refugee.
I was particularly interested
to know about the, if you,
you got special way to deal
with the challenge of tracking
those refugees.
And also what you mentioned
is that you keep this separate
sample of 5,000 household or individuals,
which you say are perhaps representative,
but we know that when people
are escaping from violence,
they may not want to be found,
they may not want to be tracked.
So what do you do with
this? And thanks for your,
your collaboration, which
is very, very interesting.
- On yeah,
those are excellent questions
on the first question of,
you know,
how do you track it's a
particularly difficult population.
Absolutely. Right?
There's no,
I mean there's no magical
solution that I can offer.
You can, like how you're
imagining it's difficult.
It is actually true.
It is, it's difficult.
Now the,
what we are doing is that
we actually spend some extra
money,
some of our budget in just
making, almost useless from our,
from the perspective of
research, phone calls, right?
Just to have like touchpoint
and conversations and seeing
whether they have new sim cards, right?
Like where they live now,
who else can we contact?
So we are just the,
the only thing we're trying to
do is as long as you maintain
contact with them on a
regular basis, right?
It becomes easier to re-find them. Right?
And the the other, the other
point you made about like,
the population really
doesn't want to be tracked.
We haven't, in this population,
we haven't found that to
be a particularly like a
special challenge or anything like that
for whatever reason. I mean,
even though, I mean they, it's,
they don't wanna talk for more
than two hours. But that's,
that's been a problem for
understandable reasons.
But, but like, not
particularly that, you know,
we're getting a lot of like
refusal to participate.
- Any other question right now?
There, there, there.
- [Audience Member] I'm
just wondering for that
"MXFLS" and for the
"GSPS", if there's opportunities
like the ones Mushfiq is,
are, is kind of making available, right?
So I mean I think it's a,
it's a wonder initiative.
You have, you spend all
the money in the baseline,
which is the most expensive part.
And then from there people have access,
like can people have access to
like all the sampling frames
to be able to locate,
like do you make those things
available to be able to locate
those households to do some
other studies or just the kind
of like de-identified data
that it's publicly available?
'Cause I mean if those are,
those opportunities are available,
I think that would also make
it very useful for researchers
to kind of do small things here
and there using those panels
and then moving,
moving those projects forward
in particularly in Mexico,
given the current circumstances. Right?
- I might just jump in and add to that,
which is the flip side, which
is not just the IRB but also,
you know, ethically, how, what kind of,
how do you think about the
taxes you put on people when you
enter them into a sample in the long run?
- [Chris] You're looking at me,
(people laughing)
I'll hand off to Sam in just a second.
So the ethical issues
are really important.
It's clear that a determined
person could identify a
household in our,
in our sample just from the
data that even though it's
de-identified, if you
were to be a detective,
you could go find them.
And that's a
problem.
And that's also the main
barrier to just letting the,
any researcher join in to do
an experiment or add a small
module.
So what
our
practice has been to
bring them into our team,
go through the IRB at
at at Northwestern and,
and make an agreement with,
with the PIs that will do this jointly or
the
added burden.
What do you say to these households?
How do households respond when
we show up for wave three?
- Yeah, I think you mentioned a thing
which is once we build a
rapport with them, it's
pretty much easy and we make,
or we work with the same
interviewers so they know them and
they're familiar with
them, so it's easier, yeah,
getting them to participate
and on, on what you asked,
the opportunities are there,
but of course we don't
hand the sample to you.
You would have to partner and
then you won't know where the
households are.
But once you give us the
idea and what you want to do,
we think through with you and
then with them experience and
readers, they give us feedback
and then we communicate.
So it's more like it works
like that we won't give the
sample to you to go and
do what you wanna do.
- [Graciela] Yeah, I think
in the case of the "MXFLS"
would be the same.
We have to take very good
care of our sample, right?
So we would be definitely open
to working
with
very different groups,
but we would have to work together.
We've done,
we've done experiments in the
past as well and it's worked
very well.
- Knowing that you guys are
open, it's wonderful now, right?
- [Andre] Not out chipping,
I think we currently,
the fourth wave of the Ghana
panel is ongoing and we have
like some PhD students
collaborating with us and then also
some other, I think
UC Berkeley?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. So we have some other teams from
UC Berkeley collaborating
with us on some studies.
So we are very much
open. Yeah, I think you
talk to Chris. He will get you in.
- [Mushfiq] Another
dimension of the ethics
that's particularly, that
we have to be careful about,
problematic for us,
is that we are talking about a population
that has recently experienced
severe trauma and,
and asking questions about trauma,
so something we had to
think carefully about.
Not that we, I'm not
saying we got it right,
but I'll just tell you what
challenges we had is that,
you know, if you, if you make
people relive their trauma,
does that do longer term damage? Right?
And so we had in place, for example,
if you're going to ask a set
of questions that we will have,
you know,
support services available
should you need it later.
But here's something I
was surprised by that,
and even Poala, my CO-PI who is,
who normally works in
like psychosocial areas,
was surprised by that people
were really willing and wanted
to share their stories, right?
So we had a,
so we had a big qualitative
component as well of the survey,
not just collecting a set of
yes, no, or numeric responses
where we like wrote down
sort of narratives of,
of their stories.
- So I think they're out
time. I think, Shannon,
if you have any instructions
to give us for the next stage?